what's up everybody so if you've seen
some of my previous videos you might
already know that some boys are really
upset about my pants they don't like the
way that I dress they just don't think
that I'm manly enough they also don't
like the way I swing an ax they think I
look girly so this video is to show them
how manly I really am when those guys
brush their teeth they use a soft
bristle I use a [__] Dremel 8220 on
high speed when they trim their nails
they probably use Clippers I use tin
snips because my nails are hard as steel
my guess is that if you're one of these
guys you shape your nails with a file I
use an orbital sander with 120 grit to
sculpt an Immaculate Square oval do you
think I use scissors to cut my hair like
some beta no I use a goddamn machete
does it look like I use a Conair to dry
and volumize my hair laugh my ass off
bro I use a modified propane blow torch
stop using polish on a brush and start
masking off your nails and using
Rust-Oleum two in one spray paint like a
real man sexism and homophobia are signs
of fragility and only an insecure person
is threatened by what someone else wears